the my tassel
that is post here is the depth of knew
who
don't fall off
people like as pipolino and people
realize a friend
and this is one of the principles that
the entire ecosystem a social medias
built upon
kan voor mens can use persuasion technix
wat  do it ethically
and create and refined contentious
stories
social by design
fc corporation
content shoe story
social media
all about connecting people de people
that sells a really not the institutions
when and display and feel these
government guys crash the a58 yourself
and ready to connect  and is so
soon
whatever youtube show your trial
25 years will post it is really starting
time and joanna my iphone ipad racer the
guy revolution to make their own brief
history of 50 tomorrow and the his
dad sends me hang after the leg
drag all sex  applause and the leg false
just how back in the normal' steady hand
quickly to planchet's and she had a the
social the phantom very compassionate and there
pension  ethical consequences would we
have been where we live the steaks in the game
the pain and his mother south tyrol
will for public institutions
is the serum even has decided
rather desai the simpad for the light is
just what managers and escalations and
brings together
of the day from people and organizations
with a 5 edits net of i there
social media are gonna be some
fantastic to risk and all you a
garment there in games wit large number of
people dat is still can indicate
have you cry use it to  a very very small
number people
de help you do the business on garment
patch on the proven and say ho' it's
a volume k3 bingo ball truth importance
chausson a let's play syncron
sequential staff something north inconsequential
scarves bags very simple reason bed for
example you could  be reviews medical
insurance most pounds always updates
for music live performance at what you
have because what helps the private parties
shall i was the african are the i now
wish or  the is dead is political paris
at the just in tact and syrian with
jesse making them up lytlec noah die
kazuo they just get long plywood i drove
to you don't think with care for them
all my life perform
cihan thousand
is and
citizen dabbing together  in belgium in
2011 life in 2012 true effect who are the
largest city together tight and key
europe
organized by citizens and it was an
exercice in participa tori democracy now
just wonder define view had cousin
that certain distinction between an
architect in was the people are  people
the people soap series and
in an offline world more than
necessary logos in also by sharing
your messages and process the de feedback
you can view comments on a service is the
richest use use participate in policy
social media is a medium more people
and side there  8 rocking beacause repetition
head of their high leather post with your
don't get it is difficult to cat the
mediocre communication to beat zoë
socialist in us so that we  the the
role of the deposit of information comes
in that you become an adolescent people a she
went to the in fact a lot of people as a
price that we now our the modern
20 minutes after this action lisa mondeo is
a it excites you calls of information
we thank you about all panel